[Musik]
hallo meine lieben heute mal in einer
ganz anderen umgebung aber dann könnt
ihr euch gewöhnen ich stehe hier in
meiner neuen küche
dann haben sie und ich wir haben unsere
hochzeitsfeier gehabt darunter eigene
wohnung angemietet und jetzt wohnen
wichtig und das ist unsere gemeinsame
küche und in den nächsten jahren werden
wir euch auch hier immer wieder begrüßen
und die tolle rezepte zaubern und
deswegen ist das heutige video ein ganz
besonderes für mich und ich hab mir auch
für das heutige video nämlich was
richtig leckeres ausgedacht und dann
machen wir eine mousse au chocolat torte
ohne packen und gehen einmal rüber und
dann zeige ich die zutaten für den keks
boden benötigen wir butterkekse und
geschmolzene butter und für die muss
auch chocolart benötigen wir zart bitter
und vollmilch kuvertüre außerdem
eiskalte schlag sahne zucker und eier
wir beginnen jetzt mit dem boden besteht
ja aus butterkeksen & butter die
butterkekse müsst ihr euch einfach klein
entweder mörsen oder mixen oder was ich
gemacht habe aber ich hab' ich bin so
angezogen aber ich habe noch nicht alles
rübergebracht
ich hab einfach mit den händen gemacht
hatte da einen kleinen kampf aber es
ging und die mutter habe ich ganz
einfach in der mikrowelle geschmolzen
und was ihr außerdem jetzt benötigt ist
eine tortenplatte oder einen teller so
wie ich bin jetzt nehme und einen
tortenring und inhaber christoph 24 cm
eingestellt und für den kunden verbinden
jetzt ganz einfach butter mit keksen
solange es ist alles gut verbunden hat
[Musik]
die kirchen müssen wir jetzt ganz
einfach in die springform oder in den
tortenring und dann schön flach an
drücken sobald alles schön flach an
gedrückt wurde ist der wohl und so weit
fertig hier nämlich ganz kurz an die
seite den müsste jetzt auch nicht vor
backen denn der ist so schon richtig
schön conti und jetzt machen wir weiter
mit der creme dafür nehmen wir uns
unsere eiskalte schlag war das ganz
wichtig dass die frisch aus dem
kühlschrank kommen
die gebe ich mir erzählen eine schüssel
und dann hole ich für mein handmixer und
der mix aus einmal komplett steif so die
sahne ist komplett steif geschlagen und
es ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass wir die
bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank geben und dann machen wir am
herd weiter so die kultur ins
geschmolzen die ist jetzt noch handwarm
und wir machen jetzt wie gesagt weiter
hier habe ich meine wasserrad bei einem
wasserbad müsst ihr einfach immer nur
darauf achten dass das wasser nicht mit
der schüssel in berührung kommt also so
ungefähr
und jetzt gebe ich eier und zucker dazu
und nehme mir auch wieder mein
handrührgerät zur hilfe denn unsere
aufgabe ist es also ihr dürft jetzt
nicht so stehen lassen und habe die
röhre ihr müsst jetzt einfach nur mit
dem mixer erstmal auf niedriger stufe
und dann immer höher schön mit das
richtig schön cremig wird
[Musik]
jetzt schaut euch die masse an wie ist
richtig schön fluffig geworden und
deshalb eben auch das wasserbad bewirkt
dadurch dass es wasserbad ebenso richtig
schön wärme abgibt konnten wir das
richtig schön fluffig aufschlagen und
sie zur asterlagen sich gelöst und ihr
seht schon den verzerren das also ist
nicht mehr gebacken in meiner meinung
nach ist es jetzt nicht mehr oh da durch
das der temperatur abgegeben haben und
jetzt kommt die schokolade dazu und ihr
wissen zu einem must chocolat gehört
neben der schokolade eben auch immer sei
und eben immer in der form also es wird
nicht gebacken und dann müsste einfach
schöne frische eier ning und dann kann
auch nichts schief gehen
und jetzt gebe ich auch die schokolade
mit dazu
[Musik]
so die eier sind jetzt gut mit der
ouvertüre verbunden jetzt ist es
allerdings noch ein bisschen lauwarm und
ihr wisst ja wenn die kalte schlagsahne
jetzt mit dazu kommt dann würde sich
schmerzen deshalb lassen uns jetzt ganze
zehn minuten an der seite stehen und
dann geben wir die sahne mit dazu unsere
museum ist fertig und ihr seht schon sie
ist ziemlich flüssig wie wir das fest
fragt ihr euch jetzt das passiert alles
im kühlschrank ich gebe jetzt die creme
auf meinen boden würde es gern drüber
laufen lassen und dann wird das ganze
gefühlt so meine lieben ihr müsst jetzt
ganz stark sein das müsst ihr mir
versprechen denn das gute stück kommt
jetzt in den kühlschrank für mindestens
4 stunden oder aber auch über nacht das
ist jetzt in meinem fall so und dann
sehen wir uns morgen in alter frische
[Musik]
voila meine liebe es ist schön fest
geworden genauso wie wir es haben
möchten
das einzige was wir jetzt machen müssen
ist den tortenring zu entfernen und
dafür nehmt ihr euch jetzt einfach ein
dünnes buttermesser oder ein tortenring
messer und entfernt jetzt erstmal den
rand von tortenring
[Musik]
so und jetzt geht es an die wege sind
wäre der meinung wieso muss aus
schokolade torte oder besser kochen
braucht keine zusätzliche sahne oder
schokolade
leichtigkeit ist hier stichwort wir
nehmen jetzt ganz einfach bacau geben
dass durch ein feines sieb und dann ganz
einfach oben drüber geben und dann ist
die torte auch schon sehr wir bereit und
wir genießen den kuchen jetzt mit
unseren eltern bzw
mit den eltern und meinen schläger
eltern da fahren wir jetzt gleich hin
und lassen uns das gut schmecken heute
ist nämlich sonntag und sonntag für uns
irgendwie immer kuchen tag ja auch die
anderen tage in der woche aber sonntags
immer definitiv wenn ihr das ganze jetzt
nach machen möchtet dann schaut unten in
die infobox da stehen alle genauen
mengenangaben und dann freue ich mich
über fotos mit dem hashtag iges kitchen
auf instagram und facebook und wir
dürfen natürlich meinen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren dann verpasst ja auch nichts
mehr
und ich hoffe dass euch gerade dieses
video he in der neuen küche das
allererste video gut gefallen hat und
dann habe ich das sonst beim nächsten
mal auch wiedersehen tschüs
[Musik]